So I feel like it creates a
bias. It doesn't.
Okay, folks. Time to get started. Um
couple of things. One is your second
quiz is a week from today and first 30
minutes of class but then things are
going to come at you very quickly. Two
weeks after that is the third quiz. This
s this spring break was much later than
it usually is NYU because there's only
five weeks of class left. Usually there
are six. So the so second quiz is next
week, the third quiz is three and two
weeks after that is your final class. So
project is due. So bang, bang, bang. And
then of course you have your final exam.
I don't know what possessed the people
scheduling the exams to schedule them
the way they did because you know what
time what day you're scheduled for
actually the 14th which is the absolute
last day or potentially the last day and
many of you are graduating. So in a
sense it kind of pushes the grading up
to the very end. So that's why I sent
that email about you know this I don't
like to give online exams for a lot of
different reasons but I think given the
juggling of things that you'll have to
do I think that this year's final exam
will be online unless you have very
strong reasons why you'd prefer to do it
physically as a regular exam in which
case let me know. So, I'm planning on an
online exam in the previous weeks. You
can get it done
either the 8th or the 9th. So, I know
I'll work on the dates. I'm pretty
flexible on that. But I, you know, I
don't think you want to take it on the
14th online because God only knows where
you'd be checked out by then. No, no.
So, I will let give you the final
details. It'll be it'll be on
Brightpace. It'll be online. The
downside is it'll have to be multiple
choice. It's very difficult to do a
physical exam and grade it on
Brightpace. So there'll be multiple
choices. There's pluses and minuses. The
right answer will be one of the choices.
You can get that purely
accidentally. The downside is there is
no partial credit which I really you
know that I don't like that but it is it
is what it is. And usually when I give
the same exam online and I give it
physically the average score turns out
to be the same. So, it's not like you
score higher or lower in one. So, if you
have, as I said, if you have any serious
objections, let me know. If you say, I
want to take the exam on the 14th, I'll
figure out a way so you can get it on
the 14th at the scheduled time. But for
the moment, I'm planning on giving the
exam online in the week before.
Um, I do know how difficult it is to
make airline tech reservations. So in a
sense I wanted to give you at least
enough notice so you have like the five
weeks to make those reservations when
you can. So today we're going to guess
friends
soon. Okay by the end of this week. So
if you have in a sense I I've already
decided on an online version for that
first week. So if you want to do it at a
different time because you can't be just
let me know and I will see what I can
do.
So today we're going to complete our
discussion of intrinsic value and one of
the things we're going to talk about is
valuing banks the struggle the you know
and I know some of you are valing
financial service companies you might
have run into some of these same issues
but with a bank which is conservatively
capitalized with banks one of the things
we're going to talk about is regulatory
capital to run a bank you need to
maintain your capital at a certain level
with capital defined in terms of tier
one, tier two, tier three in banking
language, but think of it as book
equity. You need enough book equity to
keep going in case there's a shock to
your system. So, if you don't meet those
regulatory capital requirements, you
break down. And there's a there's a
minimum requirement set by the
regulators, but many banks choose to
have more capital than required, a
buffer. So, let's say you have a bank
that is conservatively capitalized. In
other words, its regulatory capital
ratios are much higher than they're
required to be. That's good,
right? But I want you to think through
how this will show up in your valuation.
Today, we'll flesh it out. So, when you
look at the company's fundamentals,
which of the following would you expect
this company to have given that it's
considerably financed? A high return
equity low risk. A low return equity low
risk, a high return equity high risk, or
a low return equity low. Let's break it
down first. In terms of risk, high risk
or low risk? Low risk, right? But in
terms of return in equity, what is the
consequence of being conservatively
capitalized? You have a low return in
equity, right? And of course, if you can
break through and have a high return
equity and have a high regul, then
you're magical bank. So when you look at
banks, that's a screening process you
can think of going through. We'll talk
about converting it into a value.
Many of you have started turning in your
perfect DCFS. And please please don't
mess with the subject. My computer
doesn't have a sense of humor. So when
you say not my perfect DCF, there's a
reason I want that precisely in the
subject. You know why, right? Because
I've created a folder where everything
goes into that folder. I can find it. So
I' I've received about 25 or 30 so far.
So people are moving along. So let's say
you finished your perfect DCF. You got a
value for your stock. And for some of
you, you already have that number and
that value is much higher than the stock
price. It might not be right now, but by
the time by this Friday, it might be
much higher than the stock price. You
have an undervalued
stock. Would you put all your money in
that stock? Somebody want to play the
game. If somebody's already valued their
company, found it undervalued. Lay it
out. Anybody finished their evaluation,
found it undervalued? Okay.
Substantially undervalued. Subst. Okay.
So, you found it substantially
undervalued. Would you be willing to
take all your money and put it in that
stock? Well, he's got a baby due in
August, so that's going to play a role
in this, right? But you could already
see whether you're willing to risk it
all depends on hey what if happens if I
lose it all. But tell me when you would
take all your money and put it in one
stock. Let's take that extreme scenario.
Obviously you're advised never to do it.
What has to be true?
When you're 100% sure of what? That the
price will converge to value. Oh, first
100% sure about your value in the first
place and then 100% sure the price will
converge to value. then of course you
should put all your money in that stock.
The further away you get from that, the
more diversified you need to get. I
mean, what I'm trying to get to is this
heart of this debate about should is it
better to hold a concentrated portfolio
or is it better to hold a more
diversified portfolio? A lot of old-time
value investors, you know what the
advice is, right? Show conviction. Own
five or six stocks. What is this 25
stock? And I I wrote a piece about this
because you can't say categorically that
one is right or one is wrong. I said
depends on how how comfortable how
confident you are about your valuation
the price will converge to value. The
more confident you get about both those
aspects the more you can concentrate
your portfolios. The less confident you
get the more you need to spread your
bets. I think we live in a world where
there's far more uncertainty than 40
years ago. macroeconomic terms,
microeconomic terms. Maybe concentration
made sense in the 1980s or the 1970s for
a US investor investing in big US
companies saying where are they going to
go? I don't think that same confidence
can be used today. So even those old
value investors might need to rethink
that concentration advice based on the
uncertainty we feel about the future.
So let's let's go go back to where I
left you on the valuation packet because
I think we
were we were starting on our discussion
of emerging market companies. This
Thursday I'm going to be in Chile and
this Friday I'm going to be in
Argentina. First time back in Argentina
in 20
years and I can almost wager that the
entire discussion is going to become
macro very quickly.
Because when you value a company in
Argentina, behind every every question
you ask is a question about what is the
country going to do? What's the currency
going to do? So when I ask what are your
cash flows from existing assets, you can
point to your financials, but underlying
the financials is this country risk and
currency risk. I ask you what the value
of growth is, you can say it looks great
right now, but that could change very
quickly if the country goes to hell in a
hand basket. How risky are you? So much
of your risk comes from the country and
the currency that there's not much you
can do. In fact, one of the companies
I'm going to value is Argentine. It's a
it's a regulated utility in Argentina.
When I say regulated utility, what comes
to mind? Safety. Predictability. It's
anything but safe and predictable. When
you look at the financials, they're all
over the place reflecting the fact that
the country's gone through turmoil. I'm
going to ask you when will you be a
mature company? Again the country come
every question the country becomes part
of the story. So let's draw some very
general lessons about valing emerging
market companies and some of you might
be valing emerging market companies.
Correct me as I'm going along if you
think that I'm pushing in the wrong
direction. First country risk is an
issue. It's a key issue but you need a
scalpel not a budget. So when you think
about country risk the way when I talk
about budgeons taking every Argentine
company and punishing it equally for
being
Argentine is going to give you a bad
answer. The way we apply the scalpel is
when you talk about equity risk brings
we look at where a company's incorporate
but we also look at where it does
business. So as you look at these
valuations, that's why we use that
weighted average equity risk premium or
a lambda to kind of get a sense of not
all Argentine companies are equally
exposed to country risk.
Second, currency is going to be an
issue. I tried to value an Argentine
company in pesos and I gave up like
that. It's just a mess. It's a mess
because inflation is, you know, it's
shifting. It's, you know, it might be
going down, it might not be going down.
Finally, I gave up and I valued the
company in US
dollars. But the reality is if you do it
right, you should get the same answer.
That's going to be my defense. When
somebody says, why aren't you valuing
San Miguel, which is, you know,
Argentine lemon firm in Argentine pesos?
My answer is if I do it right, I should
get the same value for the company in
dollars as in pesos. Why? Because
inflation is the only element that comes
into your valuation of the currency. And
picking a currency where I feel more
comfortable about those inflation
expectations allows me to stay with the
story and value the company better. I
know I've said this before but you
probably don't believe it. So I actually
took a company this was Infosys an
Indian company. This was about seven
eight years ago. I valued an Indian no I
valued first in Indian rupees. Okay. And
I got a value of 614 rupees per share.
Then I revalue the same company on the
same day in US dollars. And I'll give
you the good news first and the bad news
later. And what happens when I switch
from rupees to dollars? When I switch
from rupees to dollars, my cost of
capital went down.
Why is it because it is different
because of because of inflation, right?
It's not because country went away. This
is one thing that I have to that when
people talk about dollarizing cash
flows, remember dollarizing cash flows
doesn't remove the country risk. It just
takes the inflation effect out. Lower
cost of capital because I have less
inflation in dollars. Then I did my
growth rate and here's the bad news. My
growth rate which was 12% in repeat
terms become 8.78%. Why? For the same
reason. The same inflation that is
pushing down my cost to capital is also
pushing down my growth rate. But the
bottom line is when I compute the value
per share, the value per share that I
get is exactly the
same if I do things right. That's going
to be my defense next week when I
present that Argentine company in US
dollars is look, I know that I'm being
chicken and not dealing with pesos
frankly, but I'm going to value the
company in dollars and as long as I stay
internally consistent, it actually makes
me focus more on the company and less on
the currency and the, you know, as I do
my analysis. Yes. New York.
Absolutely. Right. It's just I mean in
you're in New York can you state the
temperature in Celsius instead of
Fahrenheit if you wanted to right so the
fact that and it doesn't change the
weather any right so it's basically this
I come back to the Celsius Fahrenheit
because it's so clearly an analog using
different currencies in this
process third and this is not just
exclusive to emerging market companies
there is this corporate governance issue
which is When when you look at emerging
market companies, many are part of
family groups. It's very difficult to
remove management if you don't like the
way they behave. I know corporate
governance became a hot topic starting
the start of the century 20201.
Corporate governance took off as a topic
in the US after the Endron fiasco and
people said corporate governance
matters. new law that was passed Sarbain
Oxley supposedly designed to improve
corporate governance and it did some
good things right it said your board of
directors can't be composed of your
cousins your nephews your uncles there's
got to be some degree of independence
but it became too focused on what I call
checkbook corporate governance what's
checkbook corporate governance you have
a big board of directors you have an
independent so basically check check and
you checked it all you got a high
corporate governance score in many ways
I think we missed the boat on corporate
governance corporate governance is not
about checks and check boxes. It's about
being able to change the way a company
is run if you don't like the way it's
run right now. So, I'm going to give you
an example of how corporate governance
plays out in valuation. And we talked
about this discounting the effect last
session at the start of the class test
which is you know would you discount? I
said no because it should already be in
your numbers. And if you're wondering
how that happens, here's an example.
This is a South Indian company called
Tube Investments. It's been around a
long
time. It's a family group company. It's
it's an old old economy company and it's
a company that reinvests a lot. Looks
like it has a pretty healthy growth
rate. In
fact, it has a a reinvestment rate of
60% and a return on capital of 9.2%. So
basically, it looks like a decent
company if you look at the numbers
without recognizing the numbers were in
rupees at a time when the rupee
risk-free rate was 12%. It's a company
that's growing, but growing by taking
investments that are well below the cost
of capital. Now, if this were a company
with strong corporate governance, what
should happen? Somebody should step in
and say, "Guys, you can't keep doing
this, earning 9.2% on your projects when
your cost of capital is
16.9%." And if this were a company with
strong corporate governance, you'd start
with this and over time very quickly
move to a point where you at least earn
the cost of capital. That's what
activist investing does. that would go.
But this is a company where there's zero
chance of outsiders coming in and
changing the way the company's run. So
in valuing the company, here's what I
did. I left the return on capital at
9.2% for the near term. And even in the
long term, and I got to stable growth, I
left the return on capital below the
cost of capital. This is a company that
is going to earn less than its cost of
capital, not just for the next 5 years,
but in
perpetuity. That's way corporate
governments. The value per share that I
got was about 62 rupees. the the family
that ran the company was a little
disappointed that I got because they
thought I would come up with a value
higher than the price and they said what
can we do to make the value
higher there's a very quick fix right
what do they need to do
stop investing right if you made the
reinvestment rate zero and your growth
rate zero your stock price would or your
value would jump to about 100 rupees per
share
second you need to kind separate
yourself from the company where
effectively you bring outsiders in to
run the company because run as is the
company is being driven down in value
every time you try to grow. So I'm not
asking for miracles. Don't take positive
net present value projects. Maybe
they're not there, but at least stop
taking negative net present value
projects. Bring the growth down to zero.
That will remove the drag that is
created by all that growth where you
earn less than your cost to capital.
So here's how it'll play out in your
valuation. Many of your companies,
especially if they're older, more mature
companies, you might have a return
capital less than the cost of capital.
What's the default in the spreadsheet?
You know, stable growth. I push it
towards the cost I push it to the cost
of capital. I'm assuming that in the
long term, it'll be crazy for you to
keep earning less than the cost of
capital. If you have a company with with
bad corporate governance, change that
option. set the return on capital below
the cost of capital because in effect
you will not be able to stop the
company. The the worst part is they
didn't think they had a problem. They
said we're making
money and that's the problem when you
earn less than the cost of capital.
You're not a money losing company. It's
not obvious you're doing a bad thing.
You're just not earning enough to cover
the risk you've taken with that capital
you've invested in the
company. Any questions on corporate
governance?
severaling
meta. Oh, Google, do you have the same
issue? You have the same issue in terms
of loss of corporate governance. The
only thing that keeps them, you know,
not having this discount is right now
they earn well above the cost of
capital. And you're saying, "Please God,
let that continue to be true. that way I
don't have to worry about replacing Mark
Zuckerberg or you know you know and I
think that's the worry you have with
these big tech companies is we've
created enough incumbency power in the
way we've constructed the voting and
non- voting shares that even if you
don't like the way they're run you kind
of stuck with them as is. So, it makes
me a little wary when I because I'm
invested in both those companies. Makes
me a little wary. What happens if
tomorrow Zuckerberg wakes up and goes on
a spending spree like he did with
Metaverse? Right there. You pull back
from the edge. How are you going to stop
somebody who's got that voting power to
be able to do whatever they
want? Crossings, again, not just
restricted. It used to be that US
companies had very few cross holdings.
That's starting to change. Microsoft,
when you value Microsoft, there's that
open AI holding out there. So,
increasingly this is starting to show up
even in markets where you thought
crossholdings were not an issue. In many
emerging markets though where you have
family group companies, crossholdings
are often a feature of these companies
because of their history. What I mean by
their history is these cross holdings
were not accumulated by chance. were
accumulated because 30, 40, 50 years ago
when they were private businesses was
just a transfer of capital across the
companies. Just to give you a sense of
how much cross holdings can affect the
value of family group companies to value
from 2010 of four Tata companies.
They're all part of the same family
group. Tata, Tata Chemical, Tata Steel,
Tata Motors. Look at how much of the
value comes from cross holdings. So
basically the the red part is
crossholdings. And you can see 47 47
37%. And then you have Tata Consulting
Services where the cross holdings are
only
5%. Why is why is TCS so much less
exposed to the crossholding problem than
Tata Motors, Tata Steel, and Tata
Chemicals? Yes, Michael. Maybe the high
capital expenditure rate of the other
companies. They might own their um
upstream and downstream of them. Could
be. It could be that, but I don't think
it has much to do with the reinvestment
characteristics. It's got it's something
much more I think much more much
simpler. How do I say these other
companies are quite the crossover?
Through their history,
right? DCS is the youngest of these four
companies. It's a consulting. It's
basically it's an info. It's an
outsourcing company, a software company
started in the 1980s. It hasn't had a
chance to accumulate all this other
stuff that the other. So, even within
family groups, when you look across
family group companies, I wager that the
youngest companies in the family group
have the least of a crossing problem.
The older the company gets, the more you
have this legacy effect of investments
from 30, 40, 50, 60 years ago.
And finally again not specific just to
emerging market companies we worry more
is truncation risk comes in lots of
different forms. What is truncation
risk? Normally when you think about risk
you think about being wrong on your year
three or year four cash flows.
Truncation risk is there might be no
year three or year four. And here are
some of the ways. One we've already
talked about in the context of distress
right default risk. But these are more
general. One is it can be a natural
disaster.
where a company is essentially affected
by that natural disaster and put out of
business. It could be terrorism risk in
some parts of the world and in some
parts of the world it can be
nationalization
risk. So if you're valuing a Venezuelan
company you're looking over your
shoulder saying what if the government
takes over my business saying how do I
bring it into my discounted cash flow
value? Here's what you cannot do. You
can't try to adjust the discount rate
for any of these risks. You have to
figure out a different way of bringing
the risk in. So I'm going to take an
example valuation I did of Aramco most
uncommon IPO when it happened like 2019.
Everybody's familiar with Aramco the
company right what does it
do basically simplest story in the world
300 million barrels of oil under the
Saudi sands. You stick your finger in
the oil comes out the lowest cost
reserves in the world right they value
the company and you can value based on
dividends. It's a it's a cash machine.
It generates a hundred billion dollar in
free cash equity every
year. I came up with a value about 1.6
billion. So whether the dividend
discount model or free cash equity model
1.6 to 1.7 tr I'm sorry trillion
dollars. Overnight it became the most
valuable company in the world the day it
went public because at that time Apple's
value was actually less
than I finished the valuation and I said
well I'm ready. But then I step back and
say, is Aramco really a
company? 80% of the Saudi budget comes
from Aramco cash flows. You're really
buying a country, not a
company. And then you step back and say,
am I really buying a country or a piece
of the royal family? Because they're all
connected, right? The Saudi family, the
Sa Saudi Arabia, and Aramco. And you're
making a joint bet on all three. And in
this valuation, what are you assuming?
All three will stay intact.
Three years ago, if I asked you about
Assad and Syria, you'd have said
dictator for life. Zero chance of that
ever changing, right? Look at how
quickly that shifted. Is there a chance
that the Saudi royal family could be
displaced sometime in the future?
Clearly the property is not zero, right?
That they will not. So there there is a
chance. And if that happens, will your
value of equity in Aramco be affected?
Absolutely. Hopefully not it's not ISIS
taking over Saudi Arabia because then
your Aramco value might go to zero. But
it might be a less friendly regime. You
know how that plays out. If you have a
less friendly regime, they'll charge you
more royalties per barrel of oil. It's
as simple as that. No, they don't have
to nationalize you. Say, pay us $40 a
barrel instead of $15 a barrel.
Overnight, your margins drop, your cash
flows decrease. So here's what I did. I
estimated a probability of a regime
change. Remember, it's a 50-year cash
flow. So, it's it 20% might look high,
but it's a 20% chance of a change over
the next 50 years. And if that happens,
I assume that your value will have I'm
just making up numbers as I'm going
along. I'll be quite honest because I'm
I don't really have the capacity to
assess the but if you're investing in
Aramco, you're implicitly making an
assumption about regime change. might as
well face up to it and say in this
company my biggest challenge is not the
price of oil or the reserves. It's
really dealing with the political risk
underlying this
company. Now in the case of Aramo, you
know what percentage was offered to the
public at their initial offering? It's
3%. 97% is still held by the Saudi
government and it was restricted in
terms of who can invest in. I think you
have to be a Saudi citizen maybe. I
don't I don't even know the qu the
details. So it's really a for
show no offering but to the extent this
were 51 or 60% I'd wage in this question
would be much more front and
center. So anytime you have discrete
risk, better to deal with it with a it's
basically a decision tree from
statistics, right? Going concerned with
the Saudi royal family, going concern
with a different regime in place, valued
twice, take the expected value. Now I I
did a valuation of easy jet, the UKbased
discount airline just before 2018 or
2019. And for those of you remember in
2018 and 19 Brexit was still in this
strange space. I mean people weren't
sure whether there's going to be a hard
Brexit, a soft Brexit or no Brexit.
There's huge consequences for EasyJet
because you know bulk of EasyJet's
revenues come from flying British
tourists to Greece and Portugal to those
warm beaches. And if it had been a hard
Brexit, there was a very real chance
that Easjet would have been banned from
flying because you had to be an, you
know, EU approved airline to fly to
those
airports. So they actually had a backup
plan where if there was hard Brexit,
they'd move their entire headquarters to
the Euro zone. It cost them billions of
dollars and lowered their value. So I
actually value the company thrice. Hard
Brexit, soft Brexit, no Brexit. attached
probabilities to each of them and took
an expected value. So any of you valing
companies where there is that discrete
risk better to do two valuations rather
than try to put them all into one
number which brings me to valuing banks.
Now I made a confession up front that
you know I used to think valuing banks
was
easy and as I describe the process of
valuing banks you see this play out.
Let's suppose I came to you with the
bank and you said look I'm going to
value the bank. Let's go through the
four questions. What are your cash flows
from existing assets? Well, how do we
compute cash flows? We start with
earnings. We subtract reinvestment capex
depreciation working
capital and we come up with cash flows.
Imagine trying to do that for a bank.
You can start with the earnings but if
you think about capex depreciation
change in working capital you're going
to very quickly be grasping at air. So
most people when they try to estimate
cash flows in a bank give
up. Second ask you what's the value of
future growth. Again if you can't decide
what's in your capital how do you decide
whether you're earning more or less than
what you need to. So assessing the value
of growth becomes
difficult on risk. Remember how we got
the cost of capital for a company. We
got the unlevered beta for the business
they were in and relevered back up using
a debt to equity ratio for the company
and then brought in debt ratios and
costic capital. You try that very
quickly the process goes to mush and
cause in in a bank because what what's a
debt to equity ratio for a bank? What's
debt to a bank? Is your deposit in a
bank
debt? And finally, when will your
company be a mature company? With banks,
you really don't get pushed out of
existence. you get taken over by
somebody and run difficult because you
have deposits at play. So the whole game
becomes very different with banks. So
let's focus in on some of the issues you
run into with banks by looking at how I
used to value
banks before 2008. There's a 2015
valuation using the same approach.
Before 2008, I tried to look at a bank
and say, you know what, I can't estimate
cash
flows. So, I'm going to be lazy and
assume that what a company pays out in
dividends are its cash flows to equity.
Do you see why this requires a trust in
management? You're essentially assuming
that what banks pay out in dividends is
what they can afford to pay
out. And then you would discount back at
a cost of equity using the average beta
for a bank. no levering and unlevering
implicitly assuming that there are no
risky banks and safe banks and the
regulatory authorities will make sure
banks are pretty much at average risk.
It made life easy but it was built on
those regulatory framework works manages
that banks pay out what they can afford.
So in a dividend discount model, life
gets very simple, right? You project out
the net income. Here, for instance, this
is an Egyptian bank. You project out the
net income. You project out a payout
ratio, which will change as your growth
rate changes because as your growth
decreases, your payout ratio will go up.
You can use a dividend discount model to
value a non-ividend paying back because
as the growth decreases, the payout
ratio would show up. The dividends will
start to get paid out. You discount them
back at the cost of equity. In this
case, I discount them back at a
risk-free rate plus beta times risk
premium in Egyptian pounds. The value
per share that I get is about 42 pounds
per share. Dividends discount back at
the cost of equity, but it's built on
that presumption again of managers
paying out what they can afford to and
regulatory framework working. So let's
look at what's
changed over the last 15 years that
makes it more and more dangerous to use
a dividend discount model. First,
financial service firms are opaque. What
do I mean by that? You read the annual
report of a bank. You're not that
there's so much they hold back. There's
a fouian bargain we've made where with
banks, we allow them not to tell us very
much about what happens and we trust
that the regulators are getting that
information to prevent a bank from doing
really stupid things. So with a bank,
you can read an annual report backwards
and forwards and still not understand
what exactly is going on. To estimate
cash flows through a bank, you know,
obviously below earnings, you're kind
of, you know, looking for capex and
depreciation, can't find it. And during
a crisis, especially, you know, you
can't trust banks to pay out what they
can afford to because they're locked
into dividend
policies. So for financial service
firms, the book value matters. every
company so far I've never tracked the
book value of equity right basically I I
do the cash flows I come up with the
present value with banks book value
matters because book value becomes the
basis for regulatory capital so tier one
capital a big chunk of it is book value
of equity and most of it is supposed to
be equity like though the way regulators
define equity like kind of makes you
uncomfortable supposed to be equity like
so to grow as a bank you need to invest
more regulatory capital becomes like
capex. If you're an under capitalized
bank to survive as a bank, you got to
come up with that extra regulatory
capital. So in 2009, as I was thinking
about how do I get out of this dividend
box, here's a concoction I came up with
and you can tell me whether you can go
along with it or not. I'll start with
net income first. Remember with the
bank, don't even try to value the entire
firm. Focus on equity because debt to a
bank is raw material.
focus on equity, start with net income.
And for my reinvestment, I'm going to
define reinvestment as what the bank
needs to come up with as regulatory
capital to keep going. So, you're a
growing bank, you'll need more
reinvestment than if you're a stable
bank. If you're an under capitalized
bank, you will need more reinvestment
than if you're an overc capitalized
bank. This becomes the way I can reward
you as a bank for how you capitalize.
page.
You have the Deutsch Bank on yours too
or do you
have Okay, let me make sure.
Okay, see this is a Deutsche Bank
evaluation I did at Deutsche Bank in
October of 2016. The blog I'll send you
the link to the blog post. Title of the
blog post was a Greek tragedy at a
German bank. And I chose those words
deliberately because you know how the
Germans think about the Greeks, right?
They can't run anything. And this was
the quintessential German bank facing
what the Germans would have called Greek
problems. I mean Deutsche Bank starting
in 2018 8 2008 after the crisis had a
series of crisis after crisis after
crisis and each crisis was another
billion dollars another billion and a
half and every time you have a loss
guess what happens your book equity gets
reduced your regulatory capital takes a
hit this was in
2016 and right after the department of
justice had fined Deutsche Bank $10
billion for something they did in 2008 8
during the crisis. So you will find that
comes out of your book equity as well
and it put DOA bank in a very precarious
place. Their regulatory capital ratio
dropped to 12.41%. Their tier one
capital ratio. You say how do I know
that's high or low? If you go to Capital
IQ, you can actually download the tier
one capital for every bank. And if you
look at where 12.41 falls, it falls at
the first quartile. They dropped below
the median to the first quartile. They
needed a lot more regulatory capital
grow. In fact, they targeted that they
needed to be at about the 75th
percentile because they had riskier
businesses than a typical bank. You're a
significantly under capitalized bank.
You're at 12.41%. You need to get to
15.67%. They're a slow growth bank.
There's not much growth that's going to
bail them out. So, I took the tier one
assets which are it's called risk
adjusted assets. this whole set of
language that comes with banks that you
can get familiar with if you're working
with the bank. Risk adjusted assets.
Basically, their assets adjust for how
much risk they take. The more risk you
take, the larger that value becomes. And
that's what your tier one capital
requirements are based on. So, they're a
slow growth bank that's significantly
under capitalized and I fix them on a
spreadsheet just like I did Las Vegas
Sands in the last session. To fix them,
what did I need to do? First I brought
their tier one capital ratio up which
requires them to reinvest increasing
amounts over time especially in the
earlier years. So basically we look at
their regulatory capital investments
huge reinvestment needed up front
because without that reinvestment they
were in danger of not being nationalized
taken over by the government like the
Royal Bank of Scotland was after 2008.
I did improve their return equity over
time, but I'm not expecting miracles. In
my best case scenario, I expect them to
earn a return equity roughly equal to
their cost of
equity. So over time, I'm expecting the
return equity to improve to the cost of
equity. The regulatory capital ratio to
be fixed, but take a look at my free
cash flow equity. My net income goes
from a loss to a profit as my ROE
improves. My investment in regulatory
capital acts like reinvestment. My free
cash flow equity is minus 11.7 billion
in year one minus3.7 billion year two.
You can see for the first four years I
have negative free cash equity. If I'd
used a dividend discount model to value
Deutsche the most I can the lowest
number I can give them is 000000 but
that's not catching the negative cash
flows that are coming up. You take the
present value of those cash flows back,
you get a value of equity today. Based
on my assessment, at least the stock
company, Deutsche Bank did look
undervalued. But that's assuming they
can make it back to health and earn
their cost of
equity. There was a very real chance in
October of 2016 that they would not make
it would not make it in the sense that
the German government would have to step
in and take them into receiverhip. I
attach a a property of only 10%. Why?
Because they're in a sense too big to
let that happen. So my guess is other
financial institutions will bend over
backwards to keep them going. So that's
why I put a f and that's what's so
unfair. If this had been a small bank
with these statistics, there's a 50%
chance of this happening. You know,
there's a 10% chance. If that happens,
my equity is worth nothing. The 10%. The
expected value that I got was about €21
per share. So this is a trouble bank.
And the way you're reflecting it's
trouble. It's negative return equity.
It's under capitalized. You fix it. You
essentially get negative free cash flows
equity. In fact, the year after I did
this, you know, DOA made a rights
offering for about 11 billion. You know
how rights offering work? They offered
the existing shareholders shares in the
company at a discount price and they
raised 11 billion to cover that. So you
saw that negative free cash equity play
out. The delusion is already built in.
So if you have a trouble bank, you
bigger hole to fill. But if you have a
bank like City or JP Morgan, it's a much
easier fix to make because you're
already pretty close to regulatory
capital ratio. there your value is
almost entirely going to be driven by
what kind of return in equity do you
make relative to your cost of equity.
So, how many of you are valing financial
service companies? Because with banks,
the regulatory capital works with
insurance companies, you're going to
have a tough time getting an equivalent.
So, you'll have to come up with your own
proxy for what reinvestment looks like.
But it it takes a little more of a, you
know, ch it's a little more of a
challenge coming up with what you call
that reinvestment number.
One final point now we talk about
financial service companies know banks
insurance company payment processing
companies the way you build up to the
cash flows has to reflect how they make
money you know what I mean by payment
processing companies right Mastercard
Visa the old time
PayPal so to estimate the cash flows the
income they will make you have to start
with how they make money if you have
Mastercard know how does Mastercard make
Yeah, the traditional business, but now
they're selling their data makes like
50% of that revenue. Let's put the data
to the side. Let's look at the payment
processing side,
right? You use a Mastercard at a
restaurant, transaction happens, they
get I think three two and a half to 3%
of whatever the transaction is. American
Express, it's 4%, PayPal, it's 2.3%.
It's called the take rate. So basically
it's every transaction that happens in
their platform they take a percentage of
that and that becomes part that's their
base revenue and then it's an
intermediation service. Whatever costs
come out of that the margins are going
to be high. Mastercard is a money
machine because I mean people talked
about how disruption would ruin the
Mastercard business. they've actually
prospered in an age of digital
alternatives but it's based on gross
transactions and take rates. So about uh
four years ago this Indian payment
processing company called PTM went
public and is one of the wor I mean it's
a valuation that I would go back and say
I wish I'd done things differently. I'll
tell you what its biggest selling point
was at the time that they went public
had 330 million people on its platform.
That's dazzling,
right? And it was going public. And I
made the mistake of assuming that the
people running the company actually
wanted to build a business. What does
that mean? That now that you have 330
million people, you want to try to
increase the take rate. The take rate at
the time PTM went public was about 83%.
I'm sorry. Yeah. 83% or 8%. Just to give
you a contrast, we talked about the
three two to two and a half to 3% that
Mastercard and Visa make and the 4%
American. This is8%. Alip pay was making
2%. So it's a really low take rate, but
I was willing to concede that they were
doing that to build up the number of
people on their platform. And I assume
that now they did 330 million people,
you turn your attention to the take rate
and try to improve the take rate. I
completely screwed up because after they
went public what the management seemed
to think was that their objective should
be increase the number of people in the
platform not improve the take rate. So
if they improve the take rate the value
per share that I attached you can see at
the bottom it's kind of covered up was
about 2,000 rupees plus per
share which was roughly around the
offering price. I mean today the stock
is trading at a few hundred rupees per
share because the take rate has stayed
stuck. So one of the mistakes I made was
assuming management focus on the take
rate. The other mistake I made and this
is this is something I should have
considered is in India there is actually
a free payment processing service called
UPI. The government offers it. So
effectively you're compet and while it's
not for every merchant you can't use it.
It's a it's a free service for at least
payment
processing which effectively means
you're competing against a payment
processing service with a take rate of
0%. That's going to keep payment take
rates in the US for in India for payment
processing companies at well below what
they are in the rest of the world. Okay.
So if you take a look at PTM if any of
you are valuing PTM as part of this
class one of the things to factor in is
lower take rate even if management comes
to its senses. But this is what happens
when you get focused number of people on
the platform and don't take particular
pay particular attention to how much
money you're making up.
Final example and I think this is the
last of the intrinsic know we've talked
about valuing companies with intangibles
and intangible assets things you can't
see and in accounting this has become
almost a fixation bringing intangible
assets onto the balance sheet. Let's
look at what makes intangibles difficult
and it's really nothing to do with
valuation specifics. It's got everything
to do with accounting screwing up. So
when I ask you what are your cash flows
from existing assets when you look at
companies with significant percentage of
their assets being intangible the
earnings are not truly the earnings and
what you see on the balance sheet
doesn't truly reflect what you've
invested I don't want to be mysterious
but if you have a pharmaceutical company
your capex your biggest capex which is
R&D is expense which makes your earnings
not really the earnings and because
they're expense those assets don't show
up in the balance sheet they're not part
of your invested capital when I ask you
what's your value from future growth
again because I'm not capitalizing what
you invest I really don't know what your
return on capital is I don't know
whether you're beating your cost of
capital the risk part I think you can
answer because it's about based on
market
values and finally when you talk about
when will my company be a mature company
intangible assets have very different
lifetimes than traditional tangible
assets the brand name can last
potentially forever
So the challenges are often not in terms
of valuation but in terms of getting
around the
accounting for these
companies. So the accounting rules are
filled with inconsistencies when it
comes to intangibles. And part of the
reason we spend so much time on
capitalizing R&D is to try to make
companies with intangible assets look
very much like companies with the
tangible assets. So when you capitalize
R&D what happens? Your earnings get
restated. Your capital gets restated,
the return on capital gets restated. But
now at least you have a more realistic
sense of what the company's worth. So
technology companies, pharmaceutical
companies, consulting companies, if you
don't do this, you really don't have a
basis for a solid valuation. Right?
So when you look at an
Amjen, there's the accounting numbers
for Amgen. This was the R&D adjustment
because Amjun was one of the companies
we talked about in the context of an R&D
adjustment. There's with no R&D
adjustment. That's the accounting
numbers. Those are the numbers. When I
capitalize R&D, my operating income
increases from 5.07 billion to 7.3
billion. My invested capital jumps by 8
billion. my return in
capital becomes actually a higher number
14.58 to 18.26 26, which is unusual when
you capitalize R&D, but the value per
share, which is ultimately what we care
about, went from $43 per share to $74
per share. Capitalizing R&D made Amgen a
more valuable company, at least in my
eyes. But this is not a generalization.
This is not going to happen for every
company. If I took Merc and did exactly
the same went through the exact process,
the value per share decreases when I
capitalize hardly. And there's a simple
reason for that. When you capitalize
R&D, you're bringing it to the same
level as all other capex. And when I ask
you does capex create value, what's the
answer? It depends, right? It depends on
what what kind of return in capital you
make versus your cost of capital. Amgen,
the value goes up and I capitalize R&D
because it's R&D has generated a return
in capital higher than its cost of
capital. For Merc, the reverse has been
true. So when you capitalize those
intangibles, that's all you're doing.
you're bringing it to the same level as
any other
investment. So I'm going to finish the
intangible discussion with the most
unharming company two years ago. It's a
company called
Birkenstock went public. Any of you own
Birkenstocks? Yeah. Ugly looking stuff
but very very comfortable presumably,
right? I mean they're very oddlooking,
right? No, maybe ugly is the wrong word.
oddlooking sandals. They're supposedly
very comfortable. Do you know the
history of
Birkenstock Dmer? Do you know
France? Yes. A German very old
shoemaker. 250 years old, right? Formed,
you know, created by German. And for the
first 200 years of its existence, it was
Germany focused and they sold their
sandals only to these these clinics
which dealt with people with foot
problems. That was the early
market. And then in the
1960s, a German American went back to
Germany during the summer and she had
foot problems, tried out Birkenstock,
really found them comfortable. She went
to the owner of the company and she
said, "Would you be okay if I took these
sandals back to the US because I think
people would find them, you know, they
they might like them." He was very
resistant. We're very German. He said,
"No, no, this is German. We do we do
only foot clinics. We don't do this this
US stuff. But she must have been very
convincing because she managed to
convince him to give her you know few
hundred pairs of shoes. I know how she
flew with those many that many shoes on
a flight but I guess the the weight
requirements were not as rigorous. She
flew them to a store in LA and the rest
as they say is cultural history cuz
somewhere in the late 60s a hippie
wandered into that store. And what was
the essence of hippieom? That you did
not want to be like traditional people.
Traditional people in the 1960s wore
suits and shoes. And as a hippie, you
didn't want to do
either. So it took off in the 1970s. In
fact, there are pictures from Woodstock
in the
1970s. There, if you've seen pictures of
Woodstock, it's raining. It's upstate
New York. And your people in Birkenstock
must have been incredibly uncomfortable.
But it became part of that rebel that
was the start starting of the brand name
building up for for Birkenstock. If you
don't want to be like everybody else,
you wear Birkenstock. So Birkenstock
sold on that basis. Then it leveled off.
In 1992, a 16-year-old model called Kate
Moss became one of them was on the cover
of Vogue wearing
Birkenstock. And again it took off on
campuses and then it became the choice
for celebrities around the world and
they did it without I mean Birkenstock
has never paid a celebrity to wear this
their shoes. The best kind of
advertising you can get but Steve Jobs
wore Birkenstock. His Birkenstock
actually went on sale a couple of years
ago. Somebody paid $250,000 for it. I
hope they're not wearing it around. You
know he paid $250,000. you put it up on
the wall and you said those are Steve
Jobs Birk and
stuff. But the point I'm making is when
we think of brand name, we think of lots
of advertising. We forget the fact that
a lot of brand name value comes from
being in the right place at the right
time and accidents in
history. So in
2023, Birkenstock went
public. And the time they went public
there were four intangibles that I could
think of. But basically if you look at
intangibles this is a point I made the
it has to show up somewhere in the
numbers right the cash flows the growth
rate the discount rate you name the
intangible I'm looking for a place to
put it in most cases finding a specific
intangible is tough to do specific place
to put it is tough to do the case of
Birkenstock here are the four
intangibles first there is the branding
it's one of the most recognized names in
shoe wear in the world and could talk
about how it got there. Second, the
celebrity customer base that people who
wear Birkenstock and they're visible
Oscars. I've seen people collect their
Oscars wearing Birkenstock.
Third, Birkenstock until 2011 was
familyrun as a company. In 2011, they
hired this guy Oliver Reich, who's
turned out to be an incredibly good CEO
for the company cuz it was a company
that was leveling off in terms of
growth, seven or eight% when he came in.
We managed to make that growth 15 20%.
By partnering with big brand name
companies. There's a version of
Birkenstock. It's a Prada Birkenstock.
It's cost $1,200 where he partnered with
Prada saying look you know we take the
Birkenstock we'll put a Prada imprint
whatever that is on it. Do you have
Prada Birkenstock? Okay $1,200 sounds
like a little bit of a stretch. But
basically he did things that preserved
the brand name and found growth. And
finally, in the summer leading up to the
IPO, and this was completely unplanned
on the part of Birkenstock, the Barbie
movie came out. You think, what's a
Barbie movie got to do with Birkenstock?
Remember the Barbie
movie? She wears picked Birkenstock in
it, and sales of Birkenstock took off
that summer, increased by 30%. But what
is more interesting is the kind of
people who came in and bought
Birkenstock.
I don't want to insult Dougmar but I
think that the median Birkenstock buyer
tends to
be female and older right since you know
and this brought in a new Did you start
buying the Birkenstock after the Barbie
Barbie movie? Okay not now but basically
it brought in a new market into the
company and essentially Greece. So, I
wanted to value Birkenstock for its IPO,
but I also wanted to break out how much
of the value came from each of these
four. I'm going to play a game here
where I'm going to try to separate the
four. It's not always going to work out,
but here's where I put in each of these
these intangibles. First, for the
revenue growth, I used to revenue growth
of 25%. Which for an established
footwear company is high, but it's high
because they've got that management
finding new partnership. So I attributed
that to great management. The first year
though was the Barbie buzz. So after the
25% it drops off. So I brought the
Barbie buzz in and the management
through the revenue
growth. The margins for Birkenstock are
about 23 to 24%. That's much higher than
even nameear footwear companies. That's
a brand name playing out. So, I put the
the mar the brand name into the margin
because they can get celebrities to do
advertising for them for free. Remember,
this is their capital expenditure.
They're going to be able to get much
more revenue per dollar of capital than
a typical footwear
company. And that was where I put in the
celebrity. And the fact that their
production is centered in Germany makes
it easier for them to control the supply
chain. So essentially I looked at all of
the intangibles and found a place to put
them in there. The value p the value for
equity that I got was about 8 thou 8 8.4
billion. They actually went public
around 8 billion. I don't know what
they're trading at right now. But my
objective was was to show that the
intangibles were all in there. In fact,
when I was done with the valuation, I
said, "What if Burkenstock loses all of
its intangibles, its brand name, its
celebrity clientele, its good
management, and the Barbie bush, its
value would have been about 2.6 billion.
In fact, each of the chunks I've
separated out. It worked here because I
was able to at least separate out which
input was driven by which intangible.
But in many cases, they're all going to
be mixed together. If you ask me to
value each of the intangibles at Apple
separately, I'm going to very quickly
give up because I don't know where the
operating system shows up. I don't know
where the styling shows up. So
essentially, all of those things are in
the value. But if you do it right, all
of your intangibles should be somewhere
in there. Jessica, you were talking
about intangibles during the just before
the break, you sent an email about
intangibles after listening to Scott,
right? Um and do you remember what the
what the email
was? So essentially that becomes the
challenge. Not that intangibles don't
have values. Finding an input that you
put that intangible into you know
because if it doesn't affect the numbers
it's just not going to show up in value.
If it doesn't show up in value why are
we spending time talking about it?
Right? So essentially anything of
substance should show up somewhere in
the numbers. And here I've tried to show
it in the inputs.
valuing cyclical and commodity
companies. It's the biggest challenge.
We mature commodity company, but every
time the commodity price moves,
everything changes. Let's take an oil
company, right? Say oil prices is right
now at $74 a barrel. I say, what are
your cash flows in existing assets? You
show me your cash flows look pretty
good. What's the value of growth again?
$74 a barrel. most of your reserves are
viable. The value of growth is good. How
risky are you? You're generating enough
in cash flows. You don't feel very
risky. When will you be a mature
company? You give me this pathway. Maybe
with declining growth in perpetuity, but
when you're at $74 a barrel, I'll get
one set of answers. Let's say I show up
two months from now and the price per
barrel has dropped to $40 a barrel. Same
company, every single question. I'm
going to get a very different answer,
right? At $40 a barrel, you're probably
losing
money. The value of your growth is
negative. All your reserves have turned
nonviable. You become very risky. Not
because you have more debt, but because
that debt is now sustained by much less
in earnings and much less in
equity. I ask you when will you be a
mature company? There's a very real
chance you won't make it if oil prices
stay at 40. I show back two months
later, it's $120 a barrel. Everything
again changes. So the same company every
single question the answer you get is
going to depend on what the price of the
commodity is. So the risk of stating the
obvious with these companies it's the
macro assumption that drives the value
of the company. An oil company it's the
oil price. Gold mining company it's the
gold price. And that'll lead you tempt
you to to say let me focus on
forecasting oil prices to value an oil
company or gold price to value gold
company. And I strongly encourage you
not to do that. And here's why. Let's
assume that you believe that oil price
will double over the next 5 years.
You've talked to experts, you've done
your research, that oil price will go
from 74 to $150 a barrel over the next 5
years. If you value an oil company with
those assumptions in place, you can save
yourself the trouble because every oil
company you look at will look cheap,
right? The $150 oil place would do it.
But then I'm going to ask you, did you
find Exxon Mobile or Royal Dutch to be
cheap because you like the company or
because you think oil price would
double? The answer matters, right?
Because if it's because oil price will
double, why am I looking at Exxon Mobile
or Royal Dutch as a far simpler way for
me to make money, which is just go out
and play oil futures or oil options,
make my money directly on the commodity.
I know it's going to be difficult to do,
but your objective when you value
commodity companies is to try to be as
commodity price neutral as you can get.
It's more difficult than it sounds. As
you'll see when I try to value Royal
Dutch, you want to try to keep your
assumptions about the commodity price
out of your valuation. So, let me give
you an example. And you know, this is
where I think using probabilistic tools
can help you. I mean, I'm a great
believer in Monte Carlo simulations when
you feel a lot of uncertainty. For those
of you who never used crystal ball, I
think know I think Stern has a free
version. Try it out. It takes any Excel
spreadsheet and allows you to convert it
into a Monte Carlo simulation. You take
your base case assumptions. Don't do
this for your DCF for this week. But if
you want to, you can take your DCF and
very quickly make it into Monte Carlo
simulation where you take your core
assumptions, revenue, growth, margins,
reinvestment, and make them into
distributions. In a simulation, you
basically run multiple outcomes. I think
crystal ball default is
10,000 simulations and it gives you a
value under each one. So the company I'm
going to use for this is Royal
Dutch. Royal Dutch, you know, oldtime
oil company.
This is a valuation I did March of
2016. At that time, the oil price was
about $40 a
barrel. I first had to restate the
revenues for oil Dutch at $40 a barrel.
Why? Because oil prices had fallen
during the course of the previous 12
months from $65 to $40. If I took the
trailing 12-month numbers, they
reflected a much higher oil price. So, I
actually had to restate the revenues
with the oil price at
$40. That lowered the revenues, lowered
the income, but ultimately the value per
share that I got was about $39 per
share. Stock was trading at 42. But it's
very dependent on what oil prices are.
If oil prices go to $60 a barrel, that
value per share will go to $55 per
share. If they drop to $20 a barrel, the
oil price, the stock price probably drop
to $15 per share. So what here's what I
did. I first looked at how Royal
Duchess's revenues had moved as a
function of oil prices over time. So
that's 1988 through 2015. The re the red
columns are the revenues per year. The
line superimposed on it the average oil
price per year. Just look take a look at
the two series. Obviously they move
together. You don't believe me? I can
give you an R squ. It's 96%.
This is as about as pure an oil price
play as you can get. See this regression
up there that I've run against the oil
price? That will allow me to tell you
whatever the oil prices, what the
revenues will be as a function. Every $1
increase in the oil price increases my
revenues by about $4
billion. So that's the number that I
used in fact on the previous page. See
that equation that came from running
this regression. and it allows me to
state what the revenues will be at any
given oil price. And here's the final
piece. Oil prices. Oil is publicly
traded. So I was able to get a
distribution by looking at oil prices
historically. And here's how Excel the
crystal ball works. You pull a price out
of the
distribution. Estimate the revenues at
that price. Operating income value.
Repeat it over and over again. So first
run it might pull out a $52 oil price.
Compute the revenues based on $52
operating income value. Do it again and
again. At the end of the process what
you have is a distribution of value per
share. See the median value $37. That's
very close to what I got in my base
case. That shouldn't surprise you. My
distributions are built around the same
expected values. But I get a lot more
information in a simulation.
I can tell you worst case, best case,
they're embedded in there, right? The
zero and the 100%. But the more useful
are the 10th and the 90th percentile, I
think of those as my reasonable ranges
for the value per
share. This morning, I was valuing BYD.
You know, as you you read my post on
Tesla, I said I'm interested in BYD as a
company. Right now, it's trading at
about $102 the ADRs, which is
significantly above my value per share.
My I did a distribution. My base case
value was about $80 per share. My 30th
percentile was about 72 $70 per share. I
put in a limit buy this morning at $70
per share. Zero chance of it happening
the near term, but who knows, right?
Things can change in a hurry. So often
one of the nice things about doing a
simulation is you do a simulation the
stock might look undervalued or fair
value now but you can put a limit buy
and put a good till cancelled and just
don't forget about it because something
bad happens you want to make sure you
revisit it but it allows me to kind of
put that in. And the reason I want to
put that in is if the stock drops to 70
and I then go and say I'm going to think
about buying I won't feel like buying it
then because I'm going to have second
thoughts. everybody's selling the stock.
It's a great way of taking actions that
you don't think you can pull off
psychologically and making them
automatic. And once it's in your
portfolio, if you want to put a limit
sell at a at the 70th percentile, it
becomes a way again that you can take
that out of your hands as well because
if a stock goes up in your hands, you
feel the urge to hold on. It's done so
well, I don't want to let go. Nice thing
about simulations, it allows you to kind
of automate that part of the process
where you feel your psychological
weaknesses might get in the way of your
investing. So you're going to value your
company, you come up with the value
base. So all of this discussion has been
about intrinsic valuation, cash flows,
growth and risk. You're competing in the
marketplace where you're mostly traders,
right? people driving the price demand
and supply start of the class I talked
about how the two can give you very
different end games that what you get as
a value per share and what you get as a
price be different and there can be a
gap in fact if you believe in efficient
markets that there is no gap the two
numbers should converge but to the
extent that you don't there can be a gap
and for you to make money that gap has
to close something has to happen a
catalyst so the rest of this us. We're
going to put intrinsic value to the
background and talk more about price.
But to complete our discussion of
intrinsic value, think about what you
have to do differently when you do
pricing. You almost have to have a
mindset shift. You're no longer thinking
about what's the right way to estimate
cash flows. You're thinking about what
do other investors do to come up with
the price of the stock. For some of you,
that might actually be a more
comfortable place to be rather than
trying to assess cash flows, growth, and
risk. So when you think about value
versus price, if you're a person who
believes in efficient markets, there is
no gap. What should you do? Buy index
funds. Have any of you seen this new
documentary that I read about in the
Wall Street Journal yesterday? No. It's
created by the guy who founded Dimension
Funds. His name is Booth. I I'll send
you the link. It's actually a
documentary about index funds and why
for most investors it is the right
choice.
And essentially you're taking the point
of view that if there's a gap, it's
completely random. We can't figure out
which direction it is. If you're a value
extremist, you know who I'm talking
about, the people who show up in Omaha
every year, then you believe you own the
high ground in value. That the price is
always wrong. It'll move to
you. At the other extreme, you have the
pricing. It says there's no such thing
as value. It's all about demand and
supply.
I'm not going to push you into one of
these three camps, but clearly there are
these three camps of view about value
versus price and how to look at the
gap. So let's talk a little bit about
when you value company, what the dilemma
is that you face. And this goes back to
the start of the class today. When you
value company, you feel uncertainty
about your estimated value. As you work
through the DCF, you say, "How do I know
I'm right? How do I know I'm right? Is
revenue growth?" Okay? And the answer is
nobody can check off and say yes, you're
right. You're uncertain about your
inputs. Maybe you can say look and I can
go out and collect more information. But
in my experience, collecting more
information doesn't make you feel more
certain. It makes you feel more
uncertain. I've been trying to value
Marcado Libre for the last couple of
days. It's a messy company. It's the
Amazon of Latin America, but it's a
company where you've got this very big
fintech arm for the company, which makes
it different from Amazon. I'm trying to
collect information on what exactly
they're doing, how they make money. And
the more information I collect, the more
confused I get about exactly what their
competitive edge is. You can ask what if
questions, right? And many of you have,
what if my growth is high? What? But at
the end of the process, you still have a
value and a price.
Or you can do a Monte Carlo simulation.
As I said, you don't have to do it for
this particular version, but if you want
to bring crystal ball in, take your DCF
and make into a Monte Carlo simulation.
But the bottom line is even if you do
all of this stuff, you will have an
estimate of value and you will feel
uncertain about that estimate. You'll
also feel uncertain about when or
whether the gap will close. So let's say
there's a value in a price. Why should
it close? There's no guarantee that it
has to
close. And even if it's going to close,
how do you know when it's going to
happen? So as a valuate, those are the
two big dilemmas you face. As a pricer,
we can talk about the dilemmas you face
as well. But if you think about that gap
specifically and say, what can cause it
to change? Here are the here are the
perspectives you can bring in. The first
is what I call the karmic view, which is
have the value, there's the price,
there's nothing I can do about it. I'm
just going to go back to the rest of my
life and hope the price adjusts to
value. For many of us that's often the
only choice. The second is if you can
and very few of us have this capacity
and you can look for you can be the
catalyst to cause the price to move to
value. It gives you a lot more power.
You know at the start of the class I
talked about the advantage that a car
can or a Bill Aman can have that you and
I don't which is they take a position of
stock and they can try to talk the price
to the value.
But even if you don't have that
capacity, maybe you can look for things
that can cause that change to happen.
You know, one of the things I look for
when I have a badly managed company, I'm
saying, will there be change? I look at
the age of the CEO, very morbid
exercise, but there will be when you
have a change in management, some kind
of reassessment of the company. You're
looking for things that will make the
market reassess value. doesn't always
work, but when you're screening for
cheap stocks, maybe add a screen for
something that'll provide the cattle
something that'll make the price adjust
to
value. But you got the value, that's all
you can control. There's a price that's
out of your control. And for the most
part, you have to just hope and pray
that the price will move to
value. I've got to update this, but know
I've been valuing Apple off and on now
for a decade. And as I said upfront, I'm
biased. I love the company, right? But
I've over time learned to put some
distance between me and the company in
terms of valuing the company. So I first
valued 2011, my value per share was 69.
The stock price was 54. The undervalued
value again 2012 close to fair value
under you can look across time. It's
gone undervalued, overvalued,
undervalued, overvalued. This is stock
that at least from my perspective the
market has a trouble nailing down
because it keeps thinking Apple is a
growth company and then getting
disappointed that it's not a growth
company. So almost you can go update by
update. If an update works really well
investor say it's back again it's going
to be double digit growth in you know
update does smartphone update doesn't go
well then everything goes to the other
extreme. But when you're an investor,
you're trying to take advantage of that
back and forth that the market makes. So
with Apple, I've actually bought and
sold the stock multiple times just like
I did Amazon over the life over the last
15 years. For the last four or five
years, it stayed because it looks like
the market's finally figured out that
this is not a high growth company.
That's a mature growth company that as
long as those updates keep working,
we'll continue to be a cash machine.
But often that's what you're looking for
as an investor is that steady state. So
you can just hold on beyond that steady
state. But until you get there, you will
have this adjustment
process. You recognize that my favorite
movie. Anybody recognize the
movie? The Wizard of Oz. Right. Anybody
know the story of the Wizard of Oz? As
I'm as I tell you the story, don't jump
down my throat saying that's so
unrealistic. It starts with this girl
called Dorothy who lives in
Kansas. Is it a tornado that sucks her
up? Some kind of weird storm picks her
up, dumps her into this mythical land of
Oz where she lands on top of a
witch, wicked witch of the west, east,
one of one of those wicked witches and
she kills the witch. She's facing
homicide charges. That's how the movie
starts. First five minutes. If you have
kids, don't skip the first five minutes.
It's
traumatic. Okay. So, Dorothy wants to go
back to Kansas and she turns to this
munchkin standing by the side of the
path and she says, "How do I get back to
Kansas?" He says, "I've never heard of
Kansas. Go ask the Wizard of
Oz." He knows the answer to
everything. And she says, "How do I get
to the Wizard of Oz?" And she says,
"Follow the yellow brick road for three
hours. We follow Dorothy down the yellow
brick road. She never walks. She hops.
She skips. She jumps, you know. And
along the way, she acquires a mortly
crew, a lion that wants courage, a tin
man, a scarecrow. They all want
something. They're all told, "Go see the
Wizard of Oz. He has the answer to
everything." So 3 hours later, they make
it into the chamber of the Wizard of Oz.
They're there. Each of them states what
they came for. And the wizard says, he's
behind a curtain. He says, "Come back
tomorrow." It's like a government
office. He said, "We've come three hours
in this movie to get here. Now, we'd
like an answer." And then the curtain
drops and they realize there is no
Wizard of Oz. There's this guy pulling
strings behind. But the whole point of
the movie is each of them found what
they were looking for on the journey.
See those red shoes that Dorothy has?
It's turned out to be magical. She
clicks the shoes. She's back in Kansas.
The lion fought off some bad guys. got
courage. You're saying, "What's this got
to do with valuation?" Maybe it's got
nothing to do with it. Just one of my
favorite movies, right? But in
valuation, there seems to be this sense
that there is a wizard of Oz who knows
the answer to every question. What tax
rate should I use in
valuation? You find the wizard of Oz.
Maybe that's Google search.
The answer to every question you run
into an intrinsic
valuation lies in the process. Right? Go
back to basics. What am I trying to
measure? And you almost always will be
able to reason your way to an answer to
the question of what tax rate should I
use in valuation. You saw the process of
reasoning you need to make that
judgment. And it's going to be different
when you're talking about the cost of
debt as opposed to the operating income.
The answers to every question you will
ever run into intrinsic valuation lie in
the process. Trust the process. Go back
to basics because somewhere in there you
will find the
answer to almost every question you run
into. And that's I think what we all
need to remember when we think about hey
because who knows what the questions
will look like three years from now,
five years from now, seven years from
now but we have the process in place we
can find the answer. So next session we
will start a lecture note packet too.
It'll be all pricing all the time. Very
different game. So come prepared for a
different game. We talk about c you
don't talk about cash flow, growth and
risk. We're going to talk about what do
other people think my company is worth.
It's a very different you know frame
there. But I would see you on Wednesday.